despite a lot of encouragement despite
political freedoms and psychological
excitations we suffer still most of us
in silence we don't quite say until it's
way too late what's wrong what we want
how we're angry what we're ashamed of
and the way we would like things to be
it shouldn't perhaps really be a
surprise how hard the speaking up
continues to feel for most of the
history of humanity speaking up was
about the most dangerous thing an
ordinary human could do there were
mighty superiors above us who demanded
complete obedience and was strictly
uninterested in anything we might have
to say speaking up would have got one
flogged excommunicated or killed
democracy is at best some 250 years old
and our psychological development has a
habit of lagging far beyond our social
realities long after a war is over we
respond with the fears of the hunted and
centuries after the last feudal lord
moved into an apartment in town we
behaved with some of the meek humility
of the cowards serf in personal life
similar principles of submission have
applied throughout history a good child
did not speak up in any way if we were
sad we just cried softly in our pillow
at night if we mistakenly spilt some ink
we'd immediately try to hide the
evidence an adult doesn't have to be an
outright bully to disabled a child from
speaking if they're often on edge
preoccupied by matters at work perhaps
or if they seem depressed and close to
break down or have elevated yet rigid
ideals of who their children should be
then a child might as well have a belt
around their mouth so most of the years
human beings have been on this planet
it's been a story of festering of
sulking of bitterness of suppressed rage
of bitten lips and of saying openly
nothing only very recently in the last
second from an evolutionary perspective
have we awoke endure the possible
benefits and sometimes necessity of
speaking up we know that it's good in
offices if people lower down an
organization speak to those at the top
we know that it's good in love if
partners who feel aggrieved and sad
about something however small and petty
it might sound speak up so as to be able
to feel affection and desire once more
we know in families that it's good if
children manage to tell their parents
they're not interested in certain sorts
of jobs or can complain if they're
feeling mistreated but the legacies of
our unfreedom are everywhere to be seen
we smile a little too readily we try a
little too hard to appease we are a
little too slow to articulate a hurt we
aren't in this respect just being nice
we're scared and ashamed
our friendliness is born not out of
choice but out of an inability to dare
to cause upset to learn to speak up
requires two rather odd sounding things
firstly a recognition that at some level
we're afraid afraid that if we speak we
will be killed it sounds odd and
humiliating but that's how little
children feel when dad has slammed the
door or mama said enough times you will
be the end of me and it's in the
childhood imagination that our picture
of what will happen if we speak are
first formed and secondly we need to
acknowledge in our mature moments the
adult truth that we will not after all
be killed if we speak because enough
people have already died on our behalf
to guarantee us the freedom of speech
and our right to cross town and start a
new life somewhere else we need to turn
what is already enshrined in law into
what finally feels believable to us
psychologically that we do bravely have
the right to speak up
at the school of life we believe that
confidence is a skill we can all learn
our confidence prompt cards are designed
to help us master this essential skill
click now to learn more